TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Two years ago, we launched
the Android Security Rewards
program, and since then
we've rewarded researchers
over $1.5 million.
We're constantly working
to improve the program,
and we've made a few changes to
all vulnerability reports filed
after June 1, 2017, including
increasing some of the rewards.
For the program
rules and tips on how
to submit complete reports,
head on over to the post.
We've made upgrades for
Python users on App Engine,
including the ability to
deploy Python 3.6 on App Engine
Flexible Environment.
And on App Engine
Standard Environment,
we've updated more
than two million apps
running Python 2.7.5
to Python 2.7.12.
For more updates and
details, check out the post.
Google Cloud is the first
and only public cloud
to deliver Intel's next
generation Xeon server
processor codenamed Skylake.
And now it's
generally available.
In addition, we've made
several other enhancements
to Compute Engine, including
increased total amount
of memory per
instance by removing
memory caps, increased
variety of machine shapes,
Broadwell CPUs available
in all regions, and more.
We've launched a
new online course
called Localization
Essentials that
covers all localization
basics needed
to develop global products.
It was developed in
collaboration with Udacity.
It's free to access, and
is linked from the post
in the description below.
We've rebuilt the AdMob
platform from the ground up
to help you build a
profitable business faster,
and to stay profitable
as you scale.
It's simple to use, and with
a brand new user interface,
has richer insights with a
deep integration with Firebase,
and comes with advanced
controls to help you
scale with mediation groups.
For screenshots and to get
started, check out the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over
here on the left.
If you want to catch some
of our future episodes,
subscribe, I suppose, and follow
us on all the social medias.
See you next week.